This is Jocko podcast number
six with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Time to get back to the books.
Last time I read some letters and
today we're going back to the books and
actually this one is kind of hard for
us or it's a stretch to call this a book
today we're, I've given
some pretty, um, you know,
the last hundred yards is a very
rare piece of piece of literature,
if you could even call it that.
Uh, same with battle leadership.
That's pretty rare now that will be fun.
And found on the Internet about
face was a pretty popular book. Uh,
but this one tonight we're going with
something that many people have heard of
or at a minimum you've heard
of Napoleon, right? Sure.
Terry leader.
But what's interesting about this and
what's almost makes it cheating from my
perspective for me is
that these are maxims.
These are already parsed down and
put into a format that's very easy to
understand. You know, he, the work
has already been done. Uh, and,
and I'll tell you,
it is hard for me to find books or
pieces of information to do this with.
And a part of the reason is it takes a,
it takes, I'm looking for
something very specific, right?
And it's not, you know,
there's, so there's a lot of,
there's tons of great books about war
and they are about war there about what
happened and how the war happened and how,
what,
what tactics were used and at what unit
moved where and how many people they
killed and how many maneuvers they did.
And so that's very interesting.
And there's definitely lessons
to be learned from that in there.
There is knowledge and that
there's knowledge inside of tactics
and you'll have the most common one
is like if you talk about the flank,
which is the most common
tactic is you know, if, if,
if you're assaulting a target,
you go straight on and that's,
that's a frontal assault.
But then what you want to do is you want
to swing around the outside and hit him
from where they're not
protecting themselves.
So that's a tactic that
can be applied to anything.
It can be applied to a debate,
it can be applied to Jujitsu,
it can be proud to business situations
where you know you want to hit your
competition where they aren't expecting
it. So that's a flank. So you,
so there is knowledge to be
gained from tactics for sure.
But what I am always more interested
in is the leadership and the the human
psychology,
you know,
and that's why I love battle battle
leadership because that first chapters,
battlefield psychology,
um,
and this is pre, you know, this
is world war one. You know,
there was no kind of Fufu new age,
hey feelings and what are, people
know the, all that stuff didn't exist.
And here's this guy talking about
battlefield psychology and, but,
but that's what I'm always interested in.
That's what I want to explore.
That's what I want to learn about.
That's what I want to compare
my experiences too because,
and I've said this before,
leadership is the most
challenging of all endeavors.
And,
and leading these human beings with all
these variables is the most challenging
and therefore the most rewarding.
So while the tactics are important
and you and you can gain from them,
it's, it's how the people react,
what they do, where they go.
Those are the things that,
that stand the test of time.
And that's always what I'm looking for.
Um,
so these kind of things
are that are the things that allow you
as a leader of other people to look at
those examples and learn
from them and gain from them.
And there will be little changes and
little adjustments and you can see that
there's changes over time.
But the basic principles,
no matter when you, you can always
learn from them, you know? And,
and it's the same thing with the tactics.
Like for instance, there was, you know,
when we were fighting in Iraq and
Afghanistan then I did not fight in
Afghanistan,
but one of my good buddies
that fought with me in Iraq,
and you know,
we brought back a lot of tactics and
learned a lot of lessons and he said after
he went to Afghanistan and he said, that's
the same thing. And people would say,
it's not that, it's totally,
it's a totally different war.
And He, so he fought in
both and he says, yeah,
I'm in Iraq where we weren't Ramada.
He goes in Ramadi and in Iraq it's
streets and buildings and you know,
you get the elevated positions on the
buildings and then you've got control over
the streets and he goes in
and Afghanistan, it's valleys
and hills and you know,
your kid, the elevated position on the
hills and, and it's pretty much the,
you know, the same thing. Are there
differences? Absolutely. You know,
but I'm saying the basic principles that
he learned, he was able to apply. Um,
and again,
not that I don't always keep an open
mind that things can change and things
unexpected things will happen,
but that's sort of where,
you know what I'm always looking for.
So that's why there's a lot of war
books that I love to read and read,
but I don't take away the same types of
lessons that I want to talk to people
about or that I think people want to talk
to about. It'd be a different program.
It would be a different program and
maybe we should do a program that's,
that's aimed at,
you know,
military people that are,
that are concerned about tactics because
that is definitely something that I,
that I kind of worship that kicks you.
I love tactics.
I love talking about tactics. Um, but,
but further for normal people and,
and for military leaders,
learning about how people react is to
me kind of what's important and what I
like to explore. Right? Man.
So interesting on a couple of things
about Napoleon. Everyone, everyone knows,
you know,
something about Napoleon,
a couple of cool facts about them. And
this is going into this book here, which,
which the book is actually called roots
of strategy and it's got a bunch of
different bunch of different sections
to it and it's different leaders,
different historical
leaders throughout time.
And in this section on Napoleon
Napoleon going into the book here,
Napoleon fought more
battles than Alexander,
Hannibal and Caesar combined.
He is beyond any doubt the
greatest of European soldiers.
So pretty good lead in, we were talking
about a guy with some knowledge.
He astounded his opponents by the
crushing rapidity of his battles.
He marched against the enemy and his
plan of battle was a part of his plan of
March.
So he's a guy that used mobility and used
the quickness in that pace to dictate
how the battles were going to go.
His tactical system or scheme of battle
was based on a holding attack against
the enemy's front to keep them occupied.
A wide envelopment or turning movement
on the enemy's rear with a small force to
spread this main confusion
in the defenders ranks and
then the decisive blow.
So that's what we just talked about and
he was sort of a master of the flank,
Hey, I'm going to do a good
assault. You're going to be
paying attention to that.
And then from the side or the rear or
somewhere that you're not expecting,
you're getting submitted.
And that's what he did.
Napoleon was the first great
strategist of the Western world.
His battles where the result of his
strategical movements and we're careful,
carefully calculated,
very,
I would say that anyone that associate,
anyone that thinks of Napoleon thinks
of him as a strategist and a great
strategist.
Now this collection of his maxims was
published in Paris in 1827 and almost
immediately was translated into
German, English, Spanish and Italian.
Stonewall Jackson carried these maxims
in his hammer sack throughout his
campaign.
This little volume states,
Colonel Henderson,
who is Jackson's biography,
contains a fairly complete
exposition in Napoleon's own, uh,
Napoleon's own words of the
grand principles of war.
And then the person that
actually compiled the maxims.
And this is actually,
this is a statement that is very similar
to what I started off talking about.
You know,
what I like to learn about the art of
war is susceptible of being considered
under two titles.
The one which rests entirely on the
knowledge and genius of the commander.
The other on matters of detail.
Now hear,
they're going to break that
down a little bit further.
The first is the same for all time,
for all peoples,
whatever arms with which they fight.
From this,
it follows that the same principles
have directed the great captains of all
centuries.
So that's what I like to read about those,
those same principles that have directed
the great captains of all centuries,
those basic principles. And a lot of those
have to do with human nature. And then,
and then it goes on to say that the
matters of detail and what he's talking
about matters details he's talking about
tactics on the contrary are subject to
the influence of time to the spirit of
the people and the character of armor.
And so, you know, that's when you change
from having bow and arrows to rifles,
to machine guns, to bombs,
to whatever. And so there,
there are drastic
changes in those tactics.
And that's why while they interest me,
and I always like to find a common
thread in tactics and say, oh,
it's the same thing that we do. You
know, that they didn't World War One,
we do that now, or
whatever. You know, you all,
I'm always looking to find that thread,
but it's sometimes it can be hard to find
and sometimes it doesn't exist to any
great degree.
Whereas the way people act and the
way human beings respond to combat
situations,
it doesn't change as much.
Yeah.
You would think if you go deep enough
or fundamental enough that it's not
surprising that it won't change because
dealing with people in their needs and
like almost on a biological
level psychologically,
a lot of times biologically
preservation of life plays a big part.
So yet technology can advance.
Even social stuff can advance,
but that fund, those fundamental
needs typically stay the
same. Him Can you, right.
But if you think about this,
and we talked about this last time,
and like with a World War One,
you know these basic needs for survival,
these men,
but just just threw them out the window.
I mean it's just absolutely crazy.
They disregarded that drive and
just went over the top into hell.
An intermission.
Gunfires does that kind of go along the
lines with something that is still here
in a big way where they kind of put
their own personal needs, whether they,
you know, their, their, their
need to survive personally,
they put the need for their
mission or their honor to survive.
They put that in front of their
need to survive personally.
[inaudible] that's Kinda,
doesn't that kind of translate even now?
That's how like, yes, yes. I mean
I guess if we say that that's a,
that that's a normal human trait,
which I don't know if it is or not that
I think it's something that gets learned.
I don't think it's a inherent normal,
normal trade. Unless you say, look,
people have an inherent
trait to make their tribe,
their family survived and maybe that's
it. Yeah, that's what I was going to say.
That's exactly what I was going to say.
So military culture, especially when you,
when you deal with the elite,
were doing a good job
to put it lightly.
Doing a good job is very important.
You would think that that culture
cultivates that need to put the mission in
front of my own personal stuff
still in so deep into that,
that individual that it does most
of the time Trump their need. Yeah,
you're right. And that thread
actually, we can go through all,
all of history and find a thread of,
of groups of people that sacrificed
and put there the mission or the,
the group out of themselves, right? Yes,
yes. I mean look at Thermopylae with the,
the 300 Spartans. I mean,
that's our classic example.
And even the fought and
died for their country.
Yeah. And even people who
aren't in the military,
we understand that that's how
elite soldiers are. You know,
we understand that. Oh yeah, they,
they, that's an elite soldier.
One Who will put his life on the
line for the mission for the country.
That we all understand that.
And you use the term elite,
but I will not use the term elite because
I've seen every soldier who wouldn't
be considered elite. Right.
I've seen them. All right.
Do that marines do that
and US Army soldiers and,
and you know,
the,
the untrained reservists that doesn't
really hasn't been through the kind of
training that we have at all,
but they will have that.
So it has nothing to do really with,
which actually proves your point even
more is that it doesn't even have to do
with your level of training
or your so called being elite.
It has to do with your dedication to
the mission and the people that are with
you. So, but yeah,
I guess a better than better than
a better word than elite would be,
I guess just like a dedicated soldier.
Just a soldier in general. Yes.
So back to the book here.
A plan. Okay. Now this is,
now we're getting into the maxims and
I'm not, I obviously didn't do all of it,
but I picked out the ones that I
kind of fought, have the most, uh,
talk about human nature.
But at the same time also talk
about from a leadership perspective,
planning execution. If they are important
and they are universal, then I, I,
I put them in here.
And this is kind of one of them that
I just talked about with planning.
A plan of campaign should anticipate
everything which the enemy can do and
contain within itself.
The means of forwarding him plans of
campaign may be infinitely modified
according to the circumstances.
This is exactly what we heard on battle
leadership from von Shell is that,
so he just said, you know, the
plan should anticipate everything.
But then he goes on to say,
plans of campaign may be infinitely
modified according to the circumstances,
the genius of the commander,
the quality of the troops,
and it's apostrophe of the theater of war.
So this is again a common thread
that we hear all the time.
And that is you got to have
adaptability and you've gotta be,
and one of the biggest hindrances to
adaptability is ego is when you saying,
Oh, you know what? My plan is awesome.
My plan is my plan is the best and I'm
just going to ride my plan into the
ground and take everyone down with me
because I don't have the humility to admit
that my plan went wrong.
To admit that the enemy did
something I didn't expect to,
to admit that I have shortfalls with my
troops or whatever the case may be and
say, you know what, I need to
adapt. I'm going to do it now.
Next one.
All war should be
systematic for every war,
should have an aim and be conducted in
conformity with the principles and rules
of the art war should be undertaken with
forces corresponding to the magnitude
of the obstacles that
are to be anticipated.
Now what caught me about that one was
recently I got asked a bunch of questions
about
the situation in Iraq and Syria and one
of the things people want to throw out
there because it's a,
okay,
it's a catchy,
yeah,
buzz word or group of
buzzwords and that's, you know,
boots on the ground and you know,
I kept getting asked,
well how many boots on
the ground do we need?
How many troops do we
need to put on the ground?
And my answer was the same every time,
which is we put as many troops on the
ground as it takes to win and to win
decisively. And without question,
that's how you go to war.
Okay?
Now,
this is another little maxim which I
really like at the commencement of a
campaign.
The question whether advance or
not requires careful deliberation.
So before you go into war,
you carefully deliberate,
and this is something that
I've been talking about lately.
When people think that
because I'm a soldier,
because I'm a warrior,
that I want to go to war and I
want all my friends go to the war,
which is just a ridiculous statement.
If there's anybody that
understands the impact of war,
it's guys that have been to war.
So this careful deliberation before
you commence a campaign is exactly what
should be done.
And then it goes on to say,
but when you have once
undertaken the offensive,
it should be maintained
to the last extremity,
right? That's commitment.
That is commitment.
Now I will say this even on that,
and that's a beautiful thing you should
maintained to the last extremity.
That's an extreme statement and I would
tell you that you got to balance that
and you want to maintain that. But
what I just said is that, you know,
if your plan isn't working,
you got to put your ego in check and
figuring out a new plan. So yeah,
you want to maintain it
to the last extremity,
but just short of elastics remedy is okay.
Do an ego check and make sure you've
got a good plan going. A retreat,
however skillful the maneuvers may be,
will always produce an injurious
moral effect on the army.
Since by losing chances
of success yourself,
you throw them into
the hands of the enemy.
Besides retreats cost far more both in
men and material than the most of bloody
engagements with this
difference that in battle,
the enemy loses nearly much
as you while on a retreat,
the loss is all on your side.
Again,
a common thread that we
talk about with von Schell,
with Hackworth in that is
being on the offensive is good.
Being on the offensive is always
better than being on the defensive.
This is a another. Um, I hope,
I don't know what I'm saying this
for every one of these maxims.
But these are you.
You know,
and it's not surprising that you do say
this before each one of these maximums,
you go, wow, this is an
impactful, and this is an
important, I've heard this before,
this is another way of
reinstate or restating the
same topic that we say all the
time. A general should say
to himself many times a day,
if the hostile army were to make is make
its appearance in front on my right or
on my left,
what should I do?
Yes.
And if he is embarrassed,
his arrangements are bad,
there is something wrong,
he must rectify his mistake.
So this is the humility of
constantly asking yourself, okay,
if I got hit from the flank right now,
what would I do? How would I handle it?
Am I ready for that? If I'm not ready
for it, how do I make that change?
So constantly assessing yourself,
seeing where you're at,
seeing how you're doing.
That's a common thread,
not just for war,
but for being a man and being a
human. Being a woman, being a,
being a person that's
trying to be successful.
Are you looking at looking around
and you know, things are, I'm,
I'm always most nervous when things are
going well. When things are going well,
I'm always thinking, okay, what wince?
When is the bad thing going to
come and hit me? Right. You know,
how do I prepare for that?
How do I watch out for it?
How do I flank that thing
before it happens to,
a lot of times people will get in, they'll
in a way revel in the success. Right.
And they'll get used to it.
It'll be good to them.
They'll get used to it and then,
yeah,
when something does go bad
or just different, even a
lot of dining decided, yeah,
they're just still into that
success and immersing themselves in,
in that success then yeah, they
didn't know what to do. I was a wee,
my first deployment to Iraq,
we were doing assaults in capturing bad
guys and we got a guy and then we went
and got another guy. Right.
Right on. Right on top of them.
We interrogated that guy.
We wouldn't go.
We broke down some cell and my
commanding officer at the time,
he came to me, he said,
Hey Jocko, those, you know,
I think it was four missions
in a row within 24 hour period.
And he said, hey, those
operations that, that was awesome,
awesome work,
be able to tell your platoon.
They did a great job getting the
information, going back out there,
a quick planning cycle. It
was just fantastic. You know,
those are very admirable. And
I just looked at him, I said,
give us 24 hours and we'll screw it up.
And I just,
you don't want to set expectations.
That's how, that's how,
that's to avoid what you were talking
about. To avoid. Be like, that's right.
You know, I said, no. Hey,
you know what sir? Give us 24
hours and we'll screw it up.
Right. Do you ever fear like in that
were in that particular case that um,
he could look at edit as, Dang,
are you being negative or could,
obviously you're not, given what you're
saying, you're not being negative,
you're checking yourself the whole time.
But do you fear that
that either he didn't,
either your commanding officer or
anyone would take that as, Dang,
this guy's a pessimist or
something like that? No,
I had a great relationship with my, with
all my commanding his officers, you know,
why are we say that's my responsibility
is to have a great relationship with
these guys.
And so he knew that I was just being
humble and making sure that we're getting
cocky even though he was trying
to fire me up and you know,
he's probably be trying to do that
because everyone was kind of burned out.
I mean from doing,
staying awake for a long period of time
and doing a bunch of hops and he was
just trying to, you know, give some
compliments and I just said, hey sir, no,
let's not, let's not get crazy here.
Yeah. Long deployment ahead of us still.
So you gotta be careful of that.
Yeah.
To operate upon lines remote from each
other and without communications between
them is a fault,
which ordinarily occasions a second the
detached column has orders only for the
first day.
It's operations for the second day may
depend on what has happened to the main
body.
Thus according to circumstances,
the column wastes time and waiting
for orders or an acts randomly.
So what that means is you've got multiple
elements out there and you've got the
main element and whoever breaks
off from that main element,
they might know what to do the first day,
but what do they do the second day?
And this is just going into classic
decentralized command because in reality
today,
in today's world,
this rarely happens where we
lose total communications.
And in the business world,
I mean I'm a text away,
you can literally talk to me at
instantaneously. But there there's,
there's times in combat and in the
business world and in life where
instantaneously isn't fast enough.
You know, eat is not fast enough.
When we talked about this with
decentralized command, if, if you know,
you get ambushed and you don't know what
you're supposed to do as a commander,
when you get ambushed, you don't have a
plan, you don't have an overall strategy,
then what are you going to call back
to higher headquarters and saying, Hey,
Jocko were getting ambushed right now.
What do you want me to do? No, I've,
I've you, you gotta be out
there in the field with the,
with the commander's
intent that you know what,
what you're supposed to do and
you know that if you could ambush,
here's what you're going to,
you're going to break contact.
Are you going to flank the enemy
or whatever the case may be.
But you're gonna know what to do in a,
in a business environment,
it's the same thing.
There's times where instant
communication isn't fast enough.
You know, I actually see this when we
work with like sales people and you know,
there'll be some hierarchy of,
of adjusting product pricing and you know,
a client will come in or a customer
will come in and if that person,
if that frontline salesperson doesn't
have the ability to make up a pricing
decision on the spot. And so, you know
what sir, I see you, you know, you've,
you've shopped us around and this
is the deal you've got over there.
I can do the here, I can take care
of you. We can beat that price.
If he can't do that, he's gonna
loose. You know, if he goes,
let me check with my manager,
he could hang onto them,
but there's a chance
he's going to lose them.
So sometimes instantaneous
isn't fast enough, you know,
it's gotta be,
it's gotta be quicker.
It's got to be able to happen with
no communications. And that's,
that's what this is referring to
it all.
It all been to be adopted as a principle
that the columns of an army should
always be kept United so that when the
enemy cannot thrust themselves between
them,
this is something that I always
preached to my seal leadership.
And that is that separating your forces,
and sometimes you do
have to do it and it's,
and it's a completely acceptable tactic,
but is always better.
To be unified is always better,
to be unified.
It's always better to be close
enough that you could, in fact,
you can be separate,
but you don't usually always need to be
close enough to each other to support
each other. So if you know
you shouldn't be getting your,
you and your element shouldn't be
getting any further away from me and my
element, then we could be able to support
you. So what's the range of my guns?
What's the accurate range of my guns?
You know, if I can shoot three or 400,
500 meters,
you know,
if you have eight guys and I have eight
guys and now we're getting further than
that apart,
that means I really can't support you.
So now we're alone and that's
not how you want to be. So again,
there's times where people
have to take calculated risks,
but we always would say,
you know, keep that, um,
keep
together. Stay together as much as
you can. And, and again, this is, uh,
I'm,
I'm talking tactics now.
This is like for people that are in
the military that are listening to this
podcast, this is something to
keep in the back of your mind.
Stay where you can cover and move.
Stay where you can mutually
support one another.
They should move to Ho up when for any
reason this maximum is departed from the
detached core should be
independent in their operations.
They should move towards a fixed
point at which they are you to unite.
They should march without hesitation
and without new orders and should be
exposed as little as possible to the
danger of being attacked separately.
This to me, goes into contingencies
where if we do get separated,
you've got to know, okay, if I get
separated and it's been an hour,
I'll go into this fixed point and
we're going to make it happen. Yeah,
that's something you're at the mall,
he's going to say when you got a family,
this is something you actually
have to legit come up with. Okay.
If we get separated, here's what a
meeting, here's what time. And by the way,
if we don't make that muster for whatever
reason, the next one will be here.
And so you've gotta have a little
contingency planning with the FAM,
make sure it's all good.
What does muster mean?
A muster means bring everyone together
and counts how many people you have.
I'm going to say that next time.
Yeah. Say mastery is at so and so.
Next one.
Uh,
well-established maximum war is not to
do anything with your enemy wishes and
for the single reason that
he does. So wish. Okay.
That is pretty self explanatory.
Don't do anything that
your enemy wants you to do.
You should therefore avoid a field
of battle, which he is, reckoned,
ordered and studied.
Okay?
You should still, you should be
still more careful to avoid one,
which he has fortified and
where he has entrenched himself.
A corollary of this principle is never
to attack in front a position which
admits of being turned.
So one of the,
one of the biggest pieces that I
take away from this, and this is you,
you should still be more
careful to avoid one,
which he has fortified and
where he has entrenched himself.
I used to give my guys
a warnings about this,
about these fixed positions that are
entrenched and I wasn't talking about
combat. You don't, I was talking
about, I was talking about debates,
I was talking about debates
because you w w there's,
there's guys in the seal teams that
would lure you into some kind of a debate
about
let's say the strategy that the seal
teams were using it that the strategy,
the way things that they, the way they
thought things should be done. And
the thing is these guys would sit
there and have this argument with,
amongst themselves and with other people.
And so they would,
they would have these kind of fortified
positions on them and you roll into it
and you're like, you got your experience,
but you're not ready for a debate on it.
You're not ready for these
fortified positions that you're,
they're going to throw at you.
So don't engage in these battles.
And you know, it's like, uh,
I was doing Sam Harris's a podcast,
you know, and I, and I went up there and
there were some things that I thought,
well,
you know,
he might ask me about some of these
philosophical opinions on things.
And of course, I mean, I was
ready to, to have a discussion,
but what I wasn't ready to do was like,
stand my ground on the topic
of freewill, right. With,
with Sam Harris, a guy that's
literally written an entire book,
which is called free will, and he has
his own. So for me to engage with him,
it's an entrenched position. It's
something that I'm not going to, I,
I'm not going to win. And An, and
in fact, you know, it's not like,
it's not like Sam Harris is a pretty
mellow guy. He was all, it goes, well,
you're not getting in an argument,
but I wasn't even gonna make any
practical points. Right. You know?
And so I'm just always very cautious.
And again, in the business world,
you get people that understand some
part of their business so well,
you have to be very careful and you
have to plan when you're going to engage
with them because otherwise you're
going to get just destroyed.
Yeah. Sam is a position on freewill
is pretty fortified out, so,
yeah, and it's, and, and,
and the scary thing is,
is that you can actually
be right about something,
but if you're going to get someone
that's got a four to five position,
you can still lose the argument
and look stupid. Right.
Not that there's anything wrong
with looking stupid, but you know,
you want to pick your
battles. I mean, right. Yeah.
Not that Sam Harris isn't
right or anything like that.
Okay.
Yeah, I seen in general. Yeah.
No, no, no. It was, it wasn't,
definitely wasn't talking
specifically about, about Sam Harris.
That's just a great example because again,
it's a guy that's literally
written a book called free will.
So if he wants to talk about it, and I
want to say, no, I don't agree with you,
he's just ready for that. You
know, just like if we said,
you know what, Hey, let's,
let's train Jujitsu.
I'm ready for that.
I've been in every position that
that is going to happen in Jujitsu.
I been in there a thousand
more times than him. Yeah.
Because I've been trading
for a really long time,
so we have that discussion about freewill.
It's gonna be the same thing.
I'm just not going to,
we have bringing to the table is that
kind of like the guys who PR who are
really into conspiracy theories, you
know, and they, if they present it to you,
they're going to have all this research
and websites and documents that they
went to in your, you know? Yeah. Even
even if your facts are like stronger,
they have so many other weapons
and they're ready for that war.
They're ready for the entrenched and
fortify like are you're saying. Exactly.
Yeah, exactly. That's a hard word to, to
win. Yeah. Because I'm not going to go,
like we've talked about before,
I'm not going to go and they dig through
the interwebs and watch video upon
video about just to fight that war.
Just to fight too.
It's not even necessarily to
prove anything right or wrong,
it's just you gotta just
fight and win that war. Yeah.
The passage from the defensive to the
office IV is one of the most delicate
operations of war.
And I actually have a uh,
a note of what I think is the most
difficult operation of war and that is
linking up under fire.
And again, you know what,
now I'm talking tactically
yeah.
To two people that are listening to this
show that are currently serving in the
military and the police linking up with
other units other from the units under
fire is,
is one of the most difficult things to
do because there's so much confusion.
People are shooting, you're trying
to bring friendly units together.
There can be bad guys in between you
and obviously if there's bad guys in
between you and the other good guys
and you have to shoot at the bad guys,
that means you're shooting at good
guys to your bullets can hit them.
So it's a very, very, very
challenging thing to do.
So be careful when it comes
time to link up under fire.
And you know what I think
of when I think of this,
I think of when you see
companies merge, it's, they're,
they're, you know, they're,
they're moving together and there's just,
it's very challenging.
There's confusion. There's uh,
a disorder.
There is a,
there is a merging of the chain of
commands of two different groups.
So it's,
it's very challenging.
And so anybody that's going into
some kind of a merger scenario,
you've got to recognize out of the gate
that this is one of the most hardest
military operations and one of the
hardest business operations to do.
So you've got to be aggressive with it.
You've got a planet,
you've got to be clear about it.
You've got to do it in a simple way.
Don't think that you're just going to
merge two companies together and it's
going to be all good. It's a very
challenging event to participate in.
It is a violation of correct principles
to cause cores to act separately without
communication with each other in the
face of a concentrated army with easy
communications.
This is the same theme,
this idea that you want to stay together,
you want to work together,
you want to,
and I'll fill this ward out there in
case people didn't catch the first time I
said it. The word mutually support
or the words mutually support.
You want to mutually support each other.
Now what we find in the business world
is you get different elements inside of a
company that do not work together.
They don't communicate with each other.
And it's the same thing as being out on
the battlefield and you got your platoon
and I got my platoon and if we're not
talking, how are we helping each other?
It's we're not. And if we, if,
if you try and hit the enemy and the
enemy's bigger and stronger than,
than you are alone.
Well he's going to beat you.
And then if I try and you know later,
even if it's an hour later,
I try and hit him,
well guess what?
He's bigger and stronger than you and
he's bigger and stronger than he's going
to be me. We have to join together
and work together. It's so obvious.
I know it's obvious and you know what,
you would think it'd be obvious to people
on the battlefield and yet Napoleon
himself felt the need to write that down
as a maximum because people don't do it.
And, and, and Lafe and I, in
our book we have the, the,
the law of combat called cover and move.
And that's what it is.
It's about mutual support. It's about
working together. It's about teamwork.
And it's about not having silos in your
organization where one person just is
going to be on their own or one elements
on their own and other elements on
their own and another
elements on their own.
Are you talking about like
just structurally where
that's how you kind of run
the business?
Or are you talking about where they
don't communicate because I don't really
like that guy. It's both those, Oh,
now what we'll structurally, I mean,
you have to have things structurally,
there will be separate elements
structurally in the military. I mean,
in the military there's, you know, there's
artillery, that's a separate element.
There's, you know, logistics. That's
a separate element you've got,
then you've got the infantry companies,
and there'll be separate infantry
companies, but they're all separate,
but they have to work together.
They have to mutually support.
They have to communicate. They failed
to do that. Well, in a business,
you've got the same thing.
You've got a sales branch,
you've got an operational branch,
you've got an administrative barriers.
You've got to a marketing branch in,
and all those branches,
they have to work together
too, right? Yeah. So,
and um, on a personal
level that say, you know,
I don't like Jenny from HR,
so I can't stand Jenny from HR,
so we're not going to,
we're not going to talk to her. You know,
we're just, we don't need her, you know,
we're just going to continue without
her kind of kind of attitude. Yes.
That's a classic example.
If anyone decides that for
personal reasons or whatever,
they're not going to
work with someone else.
That's exactly what I'm talking about.
And it does happen in,
it happens so often in businesses.
It's ridiculous.
And it happens in the military too.
It happens in seal platoons.
It happens in interservices and,
and that's just a huge obstacle
to overcome. And like I said,
that's why Napoleon Bonaparte
himself put it in his maxims.
Another one,
one battalion sometimes
decides the issue of the day.
So which battalion is that going to be?
We don't know which element is going
to hit that critical situation.
This to me is the bringing it back to,
you know, being prepared and giving,
you know,
making your teams strong,
all of them in balancing them because
one battalion or one element or one team
or maybe even one person can
decide the issue of the day.
So balance is very important.
Okay.
I just couldn't help just go and
tactical with Napoleon on some of these.
I really couldn't.
It's just great stuff.
I understand it should be adopted as
a principle never to allow intervals
through which the enemy can penetrate
between the different cores forming,
forming the line of battle.
Unless you have laid a snare into
which it is your object to draw him.
This is very simple for people that
are in the military to understand it.
I just kind of talked about it.
If you and I are the good
guys and we have guns,
just you and me and we allowed a bad guy
to get in between you and me and he has
a gun.
Now what does that do you do?
You understand what that does?
If I want to shoot the guy and I missed
by a quarter of an inch, who does it hit?
Potentially me. It hits you. It
hits you because it's Murphy's law.
Not even potentially it will
hit you. That's Murphy's
law. So you want to always,
again,
this goes back to you know,
unity of command and having your elements
working together and not allowing
other elements to penetrate
in between your forces.
Interesting. How he added.
Unless it's to snare him,
like unless that's like you're
baiting him into a trap kind of thing.
That's interesting how you
added that specifically.
That's kind of a dope little thing to do.
Yeah, it is. It.
I don't know if Napoleon would've said
it was a dope little thing to do, but,
but it Kinda is though. That's the
thing. And this is the next one.
Same theme.
The camps of the same army should always
be so placed as to be able to sustain
each other, right? You always have
to be able to mutually support
mutually support,
as you would say.
That is important.
A good general good officers
commissioned and noncommissioned,
good organization,
good instruction and strict discipline.
Make good troops independently of
the cause for which they are fighting
independently of the cause
for which they are fighting.
A good general good officers commissioned
and noncommissioned, good organization,
good instruction and strict discipline.
Make good troops independent of the
cause for which they are fighting.
So you can actually just have a incredibly
strong force that can operate at a
high level regardless of the cause
that they're fighting for. Right.
Just because they have those things,
right?
Yeah. Like kind of what I've told
you before, where if you, you know,
you were trained in discipline,
trained in all these things all the way
down to just, okay. For example, if you,
if you are trained in by whatever means,
you're trained to show up on time
every single time where you know,
never be late to the point where being
late could very well be the end of the
world for you. Thank you. Train
that hard and never being late.
That's going to keep, oh, for a certain
situation like you're in the military,
right? So we can never be late in the
military. So now when you get out,
when you show up for work, when you
show up for drinks with your friend,
chances are you're never going to be late.
Of course. And that goes for, you know,
skill is the discipline and everything
else you're trained in. Yeah.
The first quality, and this is now
we're just going to get after it.
[inaudible] the first quality of a soldier
is constancy in enduring fatigue and
hardship.
Courage is only the second.
So the first quality of
a soldier is constancy in
enduring fatigue and hardship.
That is the,
this is Napoleon Bonaparte saying
that the most important thing,
the most important quality
of a soldier is that they,
that they can endure fatigue and hardship.
Courage is only second poverty,
privation and want are the
school of the good soldier.
So now when you look at any of
the elite military training,
okay.
Schools that those get that
people could put through and well,
what is it about? It's about poverty,
privation, and want, you know,
it's about being hungry, cold, tired,
miserable. That's what they do.
You know,
privation,
I looked at word up actually a state
in which things that are essential for
human wellbeing are lacking.
And that's what they do.
And you know, for me, you know what
I was talking about, like, you know,
I don't sleep a lot.
I wake up early.
That's one of those things that
it was pretty natural to me.
Luckily there's some biological
genetic reason or whatever,
but that was very helpful to me.
Very helpful for me to not
have to sleep a lot. Yeah.
And being able to suffer
through that well was,
was beneficial. And you know,
there's a lot of guys that have that,
that talent and people that don't have
that talent have a rough time. Yeah.
As you know,
as warriors in a real sense,
you should by all means encourage the
soldiers to continue in the service.
This you can easily do by testifying
greatest steam for old soldiers.
They do that very well in the
military. You know, the older,
more experienced veteran
soldiers get a lot of respect.
The pay should also be increased in
proportion to the years in service.
There was a great injustice in having no
higher pay to a veteran than to recruit.
So that's, that's good.
Now when I read this,
this didn't particularly strike me
as an important maxim to bring up,
but it reminded me of a story
that always stuck with me.
And so I was over in Ramadi
and I was working with a,
with a battalion called the first of
the five oh six band of brothers. Sure.
Red Curry,
just unbelievably awesome.
And our ROIC soldiers.
And I went over there for a meeting with
the commander of the battalion and I
showed up to the meeting early.
Of course I was meeting him in
his office and this guy was, uh,
was just an incredible leader
and an incredible soldier
and really an incredible
man
that I could not have
any more respect for.
And I'm not saying his name right now
because I don't want to interrupt his
privacy and his world,
you know,
I don't know if he wants to have
his name sat on a podcast, you know,
when we talk about them in the book and
I don't put his name in there either.
And again, this is out of respect
for people's privacy and also out of
security reasons.
You know,
he doesn't want to have the insurgence
and terrorists to the world knowing that
he was this guy. So, but
I will tell you this,
the guy was just a fantastic leader
and so I went to this meeting with him.
This is just a one on one meeting.
I forget what we were talking about,
but I showed up early and he's in there
and there can hear him, you know, he's,
he's kind of talking to a soldier.
I can't hear what he's saying
now there's just a soldier.
And what's interesting about this is
these, the army, see in the seal teams,
when you go, when you join a seal
platoon for two years or whatever, how,
however long it's going be,
you stay in that seal platoon,
you do a workup cycle and then
you go out on deployment and
okay,
the army does a little bit differently.
The army,
you could be three months into a year
long deployment to Iraq and they will
just, uh, they'll just leave.
They'll, there'll be their time,
their time in the army is
up and they'll go home or,
and then some new guy will show up and
they'll be in the middle of deployment.
And that's how they do it. The seal
teams doesn't really do that, you know,
you kind of stick together for an entire
straight six or seven months. Delimit.
So I show up to this meeting with the
battalion commander and the soldier that
was in before walks out
and, uh, the colonel,
I sat down and said, hey sir, how you
doing? Good to see you. He's like, hey,
good to see a frog man.
And he said, you know what,
that right there is a soldiers getting
out of the army. And I said, oh,
it's interesting how you guys do that.
And he said, yeah. And He, and I said, uh,
yeah,
what do you say to these guys when they're
getting out of the army and this is
the middle of a deployment? And he
looked at me and he said, you know,
okay,
when I deal with a soldier that's
getting out of the army, he said,
a lot of people will say, you
can't leave us now. You know,
you got to stick it out with us.
You got to stay here, we need you.
And he said, when I deal with a
soldier that's getting out of the army,
I look at him and I shake their hands
and I thank you for your service.
And
that to me was just awesome to have a
totally different attitude because the
seal teams is like that as well.
If someone's going to get out of the seal,
teams are going to be on the middle of
deployment. But when you get back though,
Yo, I'm getting out and everyone says all
you're a quitter, or blah, blah, blah,
and it's just a different attitude.
And what does that,
what does it tell you about your community
when you say, Hey, you know what?
I'm going to move on. I'm going to take
care of my family. I got to, you know,
I got whatever going on in my life and
I'm going to get out of the seal teams.
And people are like, oh, you're
a quitter. And that's normal.
And they do that in every branch.
It's not just the seal teams.
And here was this guy
and his attitude was,
he's going to say thank
you for your service,
appreciate everything you've done
and I wish you the best luck.
That guy is more willing to change
his mind because he's like, wow,
I'm working for an incredible
leader of the army's awesome. Right?
And that that story always
stuck with me about,
about how to treat people,
about how to treat people.
This is a guy that put his life on the
line for months on end and all he did was
just say thank you for your service.
Yeah, that's a leader right there.
Next one.
It is not by harangues
at the moment of engaging
soldiers are rendered brave
veterans hardly listened
to them and recruits forget
them at the first discharge of a Canon,
if speeches and arguments
are at any time useful,
it is during the course of the campaign
by counteracting false reports and
causes of discontent,
maintaining proper spirit in the camp
and furnishing subjects of conversations
in bivouacs.
The several objects be maybe attained
by the printed orders of the day.
And so this is again,
as a leader in a leadership position,
this,
he's basically saying,
look at the moment of combat all you're
yelling and screaming and trying to
motivate people. It was too
late. The veterans like the,
the veterans aren't gonna listen
to you and the recruits did.
Once the cannon goes off,
they're not hearing you either.
So your main focus needs to be,
you know,
during the the non firefight scenarios.
That's when you get people with the
mindset that's going to drive them through
these bad situations.
If you're trying to do this,
trying to encourage people during the,
during the firefight, you're late.
Okay,
theme of the night.
Nothing is more important in war than
unity in command when therefore you are
carrying on hostilities against a single
power only you should have but one army
acting on one line and
led by one commander.
Does that even need explanation?
Not really, no, not
really. Unity of command.
There are certain things in war of which
the commander alone comprehends the
importance.
Nothing but his superior firmness and
ability can subdue and surmount all
difficulties.
This is the burden of command.
This is recognizing when you're in a
command position and when you're in a
leadership position,
there are some things that are yours
alone and you have to drive from the top.
And I talk all the time about leadership
being at every level and how the lowest
ranking guy is a leader and the person
above him as leader all the way through
the whole chain of command. But
this statement, which I agree with,
as much as I know that
leadership throughout the
chain of command is infinitely
important.
It is important as a leader to understand
that there's some things that you and
you alone are going to understand,
and it's your responsibility to ensure
that that piece of the battle is handled
correctly.
Hmm.
This one's a little bit long.
I'm going to read it anyways,
to authorize generals and officers to lay
down their arms by virtue of a special
capitulation to under any
other circumstances than
when they constitute the
garrison of a four to five place would
unquestionably a be attended with
dangerous consequences.
To open this door to cowards,
to men wanting an energy
or even misguided,
brave men is to destroy the
military spirit of a nation
from Napoleon.
There can be no surrender.
Okay.
An extraordinary situation
requires extraordinary resolution.
Hmm.
Note taken underlined in red
and extraordinary situation
requires extraordinary
resolution.
How many things apparently impossible
have nevertheless been performed by
resolute men who had no
alternative but death,
strong words,
very strong words.
And we could go throughout military
history and find case upon case where I
would tell you yes,
absolutely that commander made
a wise decision to surrender.
And you know that's,
there are situations where that happens.
But I think the main point of this
is that to have that out there,
to have that as a thing,
right, right. Is Not Smart,
is not smart.
And you know,
going in with MMA fighters and
telling him, I'm like, listen,
if you get caught in a submission,
don't tap, let it break.
If you get could a choke go to sleep,
just Dee Dee, there's no submission.
You are not tapping.
Now I've said that to guys and I've
had some guys get out of some crazy
submissions that they should have tapped
and maybe they got a little bit injured,
but they got out.
And I've also had guys get caught in like
some devastating submissions and been
like, Oh, you know what? Okay,
I'm going to tap because,
but the fact that that attitude wasn't out
there. Right, okay. And that like, like,
okay, you know what if you get
caught, you know what I mean?
You're not going to say
to a fighter, okay, look,
if you could call it in a bad arm
lock, you know, just tap. No, no.
If you're going out on a bad arm lock,
get out of it in competitions.
Let him break an MMA fight.
Yeah. I mean obviously not.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay.
Well, yeah, in training, sorry
folks, if you're in training,
tap early and tapped often.
Yeah. Okay. So when you say having
that be a thing that's out there,
meaning there's almost no,
I don't want to see a shame,
but almost like etiquette is to
nuts. Surrender. That's etiquette.
And it's so much an etiquette where it's
here, you don't surrender. Here it is.
It's written in plain English.
Don't swear it. Right,
right. And it's not even an etiquette.
There's a better word for it.
There's a word, I don't know what
it is, but it's not etiquette. It's,
it's our ethos,
right?
It's our ethos is do not surrender.
Right. So when someone does
surrender, when it's a good move,
how you say like every once in a
while there is, it's like, man,
there was literally no other
option that could be conceived.
Yeah. Yeah. But to not have it out there,
you know that that commander took it to
the nth degree and said, you know what?
All of my men are going to die for no
reason now if I continue on with us,
so therefore we are going to surrender
and an and hopefully we'll come back to
fight another day.
Yeah. Otherwise, yeah,
it's, if, you know, if,
if I don't know someone even has this
much mental weakness going in and he could
get and that could kick in at a whole
nother time and now he's under this
certain kind of mindset that,
man,
I could look for the easiest way out
right here. You got real tired or man,
my shoulder got hurt on that last
one. So maybe I'll just, you know,
but if he's in that mindset that don't
give up, you just can't surrender,
he won't even consider that.
That wouldn't even enter his mind.
That's what I'm talking about.
That's exactly what I'm talking about.
Such conduct, such conduct ought
to be prescribed, pronounced,
infamous and punishable with death.
The generals,
officers and soldiers who in battle
have saved their lives by capitulating,
ought to be decimated.
He commands the arms to be surrendered
and those who obey him are unlike traders
and deserve capital punishment.
So they saying if you give up,
you should give up the guy.
That's exactly what they're saying.
Now we're going to get
in a little bit of a,
something that we now refer
to as extreme ownership.
A general in chief cannot exonerate
himself from responsibility for for his
faults, by pleading an order of
his sovereign or the minister,
when the individual from whom it proceeds
is at a distance from the field of
operations and but partially or not at
all acquainted with the actual conditions
of things.
So you,
if I tell you to do something
and it doesn't go well for you,
you're out in the field and I told you,
hey,
charge this machine
gun nest and you do it.
And everyone dies and you come back
and say, hey, it wasn't my fault,
the [inaudible] fault. The point is
here. No, it doesn't work that way.
Does not work that way.
Okay.
Hence
it follows that every general and treat
chief who undertakes to execute a plan,
which he knows to be bad,
is culpable.
So if I tell you to go attack that machine
gun nest and you know it's a bad plan
and you executed anyways, your
fault, that's kind of like, I mean,
that whole idea is you take
responsibility for your direct actions,
right? So it's kind of like if you do
the opposite of that, it's like, okay,
I, you know, I was speeding, I got
caught speeding, I got a ticket.
Is that my fault? Because yes,
it's my fault. But in a way,
if I don't want to exercise this concept,
in a way it's my parents fault for having
me or maybe not teaching me the value
of following traffic, uh, I'm not
gong to have this discussion with you.
That's just completely ridiculous.
It's the same thing. No,
you can't blame your parents
for your speeding echo, Charles.
That's what I'm saying. I'll let
you do that. That's the point.
That's the point of making it.
That's the point here is that
if you're doing something,
if this is even more of an extreme point,
this is if your parents tell you to speed
and you go out and get caught speeding
and pulled over and you go,
Hey, my parents told me to
spray even more directly.
Yeah. That's what I'm saying
is you knew it was wrong.
You knew you shouldn't be doing it,
and what Napoleon is saying is it's your
fault. You're culpable. Gotcha. Period.
Period.
Would you suggest,
let's say period,
you knew it was wrong.
Would a better plan of action be
expressed that you know that the the or
whatever is wrong? Yeah.
You should be like, Hey, I'm
not doing this. Oh, in fact,
he goes on.
He should communicate his reasons,
insist on a change of plan and finally
resign his commission rather than become
the instrument of the, of his army's
ruin. This is just the, this is the most,
probably the most powerful thing
we're going to talk about tonight.
I'm going to read it again.
A general and Treif cannot exonerate
himself from responsibility for his faults
by pleading an order of his
sovereign or the minister,
when the individual from whom it proceeds
is at a distance from the field of
operations and but partially or not at
all acquainted with the actual condition
of things. So this is a, this is an
order that's coming on from high,
from somebody that doesn't know.
Hence,
it follows that every general in chief
who undertakes to execute a plan,
which he knows to be bad,
is culpable.
He should communicate his reasons,
insist on a change of plan,
and finally resign his commission.
So quit his job rather than become
an instrument of his army's ruin.
Every general in chief who in consequence
of orders from his superiors gives
battle with the certainty of
defeat is equally culpable.
This is ownership. This is,
hey, I got told to do something.
I don't agree with it.
Hey boss, look, you
gotta listen to me here.
This is not the way we need to
execute this. Here's a better plan.
Here's another plan. Here's
a, here's an alternative.
Because if you give battle
with the certainty of defeat,
you're culpable regardless of who told
you to do what individual responsibility,
and this is especially important to have
this concept coming from somebody that
was as egotistical and expected so
much discipline from his troops to have
Napoleon himself saying this, like if
it's a bad order, you shouldn't do it.
This is Napoleon saying this.
So that's how important
it is to have this,
this culture in your organization
to make sure that everybody knows,
regardless of what you get told,
you've got to do the right thing.
And it's everyone's
individual responsibility
to take extreme ownership of
everything that's happening and
not just say, you know what?
I'm going to point my point,
my finger up the chain of command.
I blame them when something goes wrong.
I've talked about this before.
You know how many times I blamed my
bosses for things that went wrong? Zero.
Never blamed my bosses it. How could
it ever be their fault? I was in charge
and if they told me to do something
that was stupid, I would tell him, look,
I'm not doing that. Here's
why. Let's find a better way.
The first qualification of a general in
chief is to possess a cool head so that
things may appear to him in their true
proportions and as they really are.
It's beautiful.
It's a beautiful statement to possess a
cool head so that things may appear to
him in their true proportions
and as they really are,
he should not suffer himself to be
unduly affected by good or bad news.
The impressions which are made upon his
mind successively or simultaneously in
the course of a day should
be so classified in his
memory that each shell occupy
its proper place for sound reasoning
and judgment result from first examining
each of these varied impressions by itself
and then comparing them all with one
another.
So you're gonna hear all these things,
all these different impressions.
You're going to get rumors,
gossip reports,
probably heard this,
the first report in war is always wrong
can to hear all that stuff and you got
an, you got to detach from it. You can't
get emotional. You got to categorize them.
And then once you hear them all,
you can look at them and assess
them all in their own light.
Okay?
There are reason they're there.
There are some men who from their
physical and moral constitution deck,
everything in the colors of
imagination with whatever knowledge,
talents, courage, or other good
qualities. These may be endowed.
Nature has not fitted them for the
command of armies and the direction of the
great operations of war. So anybody
that gets emotional, that clot,
that debt,
here's something and let's it cloud.
They're decisions that
gets too close to problems.
They're not cut out to lead and war.
And I 100% agree with that and they're
not cut out to lead in any situation.
Hmm.
To be familiar with the geography
and topography of the country,
to be skillful in making reconnaissance,
to be attentative to
the dispatch of orders,
to be capable of
exhibiting with simplicity,
the most complicated movements of an army.
These are qualifications that should
distinguish the officer called to the
station of Chief of staff,
and my favorite of those is to be
capable of exhibiting with simplicity.
The most complicated movements of
the army. I talk about all the,
this all the time.
It's a one of our laws of combat.
It's a chapter in extreme ownership that
we wrote about and simplicity and a lot
of times we talk about giving
clear, concise orders, simple,
clear and concise orders.
So that's,
that's another mark of someone that
can lead well is someone that can take
complex ideas,
simplify them and communicate
them in a simple manner that like,
you know how in Jujitsu you'll,
you'll like people name move. Yes,
they'll do like give, move the name, but
each move we'll have like, you know, four,
five, six, 10 parts to that move details
that are important to make the move,
you name it one move,
you've learned that whole move.
So it takes these complex
orders or move and simplifies it.
Yes.
Especially when you're communicating do
this, he just said, and there there are,
I mean there definitely are coaches that
can take complex moves and break them
down very simply and that is,
that is what makes her good instructor,
right?
That is what makes a good instructor is
someone that can explain to you exactly
what you do with your weight,
exactly where you put your forearm
exactly and then and then explained to you
that you know what?
This might be a little bit different from
you for you because you're a different
human,
but here's exactly what I do and here's
the effect that I'm looking for when I
do it. Very simple. That's
what we're looking for.
The first principle of a general in
chief is to calculate what he must do,
to see if he has all the means to surmount
the obstacles with which the enemy
can oppose him and when he has made his
decision to do everything to overcome
them. Again, that's to
me is about commitment.
Next war is composed of nothing but
accidents and Avo holding to general
principles.
A general should never lose sight of
everything to enable him to profit from
these accidents.
That is the mark of a genius in war.
There is,
but one favorable moment moment.
The great art is to seize it.
It's a business.
Obviously Jujitsu,
obviously fighting, obviously these,
that's just, there's, there's moments,
there's opportunity,
there's opportunity.
And when you,
when you have that opportunity,
the art is to seize it.
Very simply.
Defensive War does not exclude attacking,
just as offensive war does
not exclude defending,
although its aim may be to force the
frontier and invade the enemy's country.
I just think it's important
to not only think about, hey,
you should be attacking and defending
at the same time and defending and
attacking at the same time.
But also we got to remember the,
the contradiction in the fact that he's
a guy that talks about offense, offense,
offense, but even he has to
balance that with defense.
Even Napoleonic has to balance things.
And we'll do the last one,
uh, doubtful general who acts
without principles and without plan.
Even though he lead,
even though he lead an army numerically
superior to that of the enemy,
almost always finds himself inferior
to the ladder on the field of battle.
Fumblings the middle
course lose all in war.
And I just liked the fact that he's
talking about principled leadership.
And I would say that
principled leadership,
not just in a leadership position,
but as a person,
what are your principles as a person?
And if you have principles as a human
and you stand by those principles,
you're going to be successful.
You're going to win.
Whereas if you take the middle course and
you waiver or the you don't just don't
have principles on which to stand,
then you fall apart.
And
I think that everybody should look to
define what their principles are actually
defined them. I can tell you that. I
would love to tell you that when I was,
you know,
19 years old,
I sat down and wrote down Jockos
principles of life. I didn't do that.
I, I wish I would have. And I,
and I can tell you that as I
grew up in the seal teams there,
I probably added principles and I,
and I added some bad ones
and I had some good ones.
And I think that those,
those principles though,
when you get to a point where you
know that your principals are solid.
And honestly to me the best or the,
the biggest thing I've done to define
the principles that I live by is really
the book that life. And I wrote
extreme ownership. That's the,
that was the culmination of 20 years in
the seal teams and putting together the
principles that, that, that I live by and,
and to survive by.
So I think it's just very important to
think about what your principles are as a
person,
what you're trying to achieve and have
those principles like a guiding strategy
underneath everything that you're doing.
Right.
And that's one thing that's good
about these podcasts is that,
you know, I'm, I'm, I've been lucky
enough to capture some of these, you know,
like the, the letters that we read
last time, these counseling letters,
I'm talking about my
personal principles in those,
those were my principles on how to lead.
And so I think it's important to come
up with those principles and define them
and let those principals reflect you,
know who you are as a person
and what you want to be.
And I wish that I would have been told
to do that when I was 13 years old
because I think it is that
important as a person.
Yeah.
And it,
it seems like anyway that
defining your principles,
it seems like that's a, um, that's
kind of an ongoing process. Yes.
Because it's one of the things where
you think you have your principles,
you know, but I don't
know, for example, you,
you could have just heard it on some
speech that really resonated with you so
you, Oh Dang. You think you have
these specific principles now,
but you haven't really defined them.
You just kind of liked how that sounded.
And you may be thought of one,
two,
three situations where the Dane that
applies to me and let me tell you
what you're talking about right now.
Your number one principle should
be free your mind and, and,
and have humility to never say,
the principles that I'm standing upon
are never going to change because I know
everything right now. And we've
talked about this before. Yes, I know.
I would never,
if I look at myself 10 years ago,
I know nothing compared to what I know
now. If I looked at myself 20 years ago,
I know even last,
I'm just a lost animal out in the woods.
So you have to, you know, build
these principles and like you said,
and I think there's a difference between
being a flip flopper like, you know,
you hear politicians get, you know, oh,
you're a flip flopper because you said
you don't support gun control and now you,
and now you, you're, you do support
it. Now you don't support her,
whatever you do support
bringing in refugees or not. So,
and people will get to call the
flip flopper and, and I actually,
I think there's some core principles that
shouldn't change even for a politician
and even for a person. But there's
a lot of peripheral, you know,
I think there's peripheral principles
that do evolve and do change and you do
end up with different priorities in your
life. And I think that's okay. You know,
there was a large portion of my life,
what were the seal teams was absolutely
the most important thing and nothing
else was even a close second,
including things like my personal health,
including things like my own family,
including things like my future,
the everything was just completely
unimportant compared to the seal teams.
And while that makes for a fired
up seal and I wouldn't trade that,
I wouldn't even want to
change that principle.
I mean that's what I needed
at the time to do a good job.
But you know, at some
point I had to say, okay,
I I need to think about something else.
You know,
I need to evolve as a human and in,
you know,
little things like I need to
take care of my family, you know,
I need to actually pay attention to them
and not just pay attention to my seal
platoon or my seal task unit or
the guys I'm working with. So you,
so I think it's okay to
evolve your principles,
but I think more important is that you
need to define your principles and where
you are.
And that also is a way to check your
growth and see what course you're on.
You know, this is one thing that I talk
about when I was in the seal teams.
I used to talk about this,
the most important piece of
information on the battlefield.
What do you think the most important piece
of information on the battlefield is?
Echo.
Echo has no idea.
I can come up with an idea, but
it'll take a little bit. Yeah.
So I used to ask that question to
everybody, to senior guys, junior guys,
and they'd all kinds of, you know,
where you know where the bad guys are,
what you know,
where the target is.
I mean everyone would have different
answers and there's actually only one
answer.
The most important piece of information
that you can have on the battlefield is
where you are, is to know where
you are on the battlefield.
Do you know where you're at if
you don't know where you're at?
Does it really matter if you
know where the enemy is? No.
Cause you don't even know where you
are if you don't know where you're at.
Can you even navigate correctly? No.
Cause you don't even know where you are.
If you don't know where you're at.
Can you get close air support?
Can you call for aircraft to
come in and drop bombs? No.
You don't even know where you are. So
that piece of datum, when will you,
when you apply that to life,
how do you know where you are if you're
not tracking what your principles are?
The answer is you're not.
You're not gonna,
you're not gonna know where you are and
you're not going to see how you evolve.
And when I work with businesses,
I use the same principles.
Businesses will go out and
operate off of instinct.
Now you have to trust your instinct
and you have to understand it,
but you also have to track what the
facts are. You know what I'm saying?
Like where are your metrics?
How do you know what you did last year,
this time in profitability?
How do you know what you did in sales?
How do you know what you did in product
development? If you're not tracking it,
you don't know where you
are on the battlefield and
if you don't know where you
are in the battlefield year lost.
So the year principals kind of just
continue to be more and more informed.
You know how like you do,
you talk about when you're 13 or 16
however old where you think you have these
principles, because I don't know, you
listen to Henry Rollins, they're there,
but as you conduct yourself through
life with an open mind and all these,
you're offered all these different
perspective that start to solidify your
principles.
So you talk about the difference
between a flip flopper in someone who's
who evolves openminded and evolves.
Yeah,
the differences that someone
who continuously evolves,
we'll have an open mind at the same time
have pretty concrete principles. Yes.
So when they're offered
something significant,
that is simply a
difference in perspective.
That is gonna that's
going to essentially on a,
in a fundamental way aligned
with their principals.
Their principles are
fairness. And you know, these,
these things that are in arguably good
as far as being part of the principles,
they're gonna evolve when these
separate perspectives
get presented to them
and thus solidifying their
principals even more. Yes.
In Echo, just use the word thus.
And I liked that. I liked that.
That's true.
And I think that's a good,
good thing to keep in mind as you know,
people move forward is
what are your principles?
How are they evolving? How are they
improving? Have they gotten better?
Those are great questions
for every individual to ask.
And those are questions I'm asking myself
right now on the Jocko podcast live.
It's happening.
So speaking of which,
we got some questions. Speaking of
questions, speaking of questions,
the first question in episode five,
you mentioned treating
people with a blank slate.
How do you deal with misjudging a person
in the event of you? Misjudging
yeah. So that was, you know,
in reference to a person that, that
we went through a counseling sheet on.
And the fact was it,
I'd heard some bad stuff about them,
you know, bad. He had a bad reputation,
et cetera. And so I was
saying that, hey, you know, I,
I treat everyone like a blank slate.
And
so first of all, I talked
about this before, is I set
low expectations for people.
I don't have a super high expectations
of what they're gonna do and how well
they're going to deliver.
And actually somebody hit me on Twitter
today and said something along the lines
of, I like the fact that everyone
with you starts at zero, right.
And, um, and he said, I'm the same
way. He's in. He was the same way.
And I think that's a, that's
a pretty good attitude. Dab,
like everyone starts at zero and you know,
and,
and that's a better way to put it
in my opinion. Expectations. Yeah.
Like are you okay? You have
a zero. And, and again,
I don't mean to sound
like a negative person,
but I just don't set high expectations.
I said, I'm a zero. Right? Look,
you show me who you are. I'm not
going to predict one way or the other.
I understand that people do crazy things
and people are crazy in many ways.
Their ego, their
personality, their issues.
I mean people, their
emotions, people do things.
So I don't,
that's another thing that keeps me from
giving people all kinds of credit out of
the gate.
And,
and I do weigh what other people say.
You know,
I take it into account,
but I definitely am careful to use my
own judgment and not cloud my vision with
what somebody else said about so-and-so.
So how do I deal with misjudging a person?
It's Kinda what we were
just talking about.
I don't set permanent judgment on someone
and say echoes bad and I don't like
him and I don't trust him. That's
not a permanent thing. You know,
I, I'm gonna build from zero and I'm going
to say, Oh, you know what, actually, hey,
he did a good job with that. Or,
Hey, you had my back on that.
So I'm not stuck in my ways and I don't,
I don't hold grudges against people and
say, this person's never going to change.
That being said, man, it's hard to
change the spots of the leopard.
You know, people are who they are
and it's a very difficult, yes sir.
Some people can grow and change and evolve
and that's great, but a lot of people,
they are who they are and so you have
to take that into account as well,
right? Yeah. When you say
like trusting someone wins,
let's say someone burns you in whatever
way and then you know, a week later,
whatever, they had your back in a way
that was really unexpected compared to,
you know,
that action that they did.
So basically what that does is help
paint an overall picture of what kind of
person this is to you.
So where it's like, okay,
maybe I can trust them in this type
of situation when these benefits and
detriments or are in play and
these other situations I can't.
So it's kind of this, and then as you have
more and more experienced with people,
they paint more of a picture.
Yeah.
So trust even saying trust is such
a broad brush, right. You know,
it's certain incentives
are involves involved.
You can't trust a certain person
to do or not do certain things,
but offer up different incentives.
Then you know you can trust them.
I think the same thing that you're just
saying is what I'm saying is I don't,
I'm not going to miss judge
someone because my judgment
is not a permanent all,
all powerful statement of one time.
Yeah.
I'm constantly looking at
people and like you said,
learning impressions of their whole,
their whole entity,
what they're all about
next.
So starting out in Jujitsu,
how do you find a good gym in your area?
Okay, so this is actually
a question. You know,
we plot to one out of many of
people that have hit us up on,
on Twitter about where to find
a good Brazilian Jujitsu Gym.
Because people,
I think people have heard us talking
about Jujitsu and they heard me talking
about it with Joe Rogan. You know her,
we talking about what Tim Ferriss,
I mean it's something that I talk about
something that is definitely a big part
of my life. I know it's a big part of
your life as well. And so people think,
you know, I'd like to check
out and I think that's awesome.
And if you're out there and you're going
to ask me if you should start Jujitsu
and you're going to give me a whole bunch
of quantifiers that you're old or you
work a lot,
are you,
you've been sick or you've been injured
or whatever you're going to tell me and
I can tell you 99.9 99 99.9% of the time,
my answer is going to be yes,
you should start Jujitsu.
Except if your sickness is contagious
except of your sickness is contagious.
Or if you're a bully or you're a sadist,
if you're an evil person that's hungry
for power, I'm, I'm going to tell you,
don't start Jujitsu because you're
going to use it for bad things.
Yeah.
And even before that,
I think you might get it turned on you.
You know how like,
cause it's really easy
to depends on the school,
but for the most part it's really easy
to spot a believe when it comes to the
gym and it and it doesn't farewell well
it doesn't feel it'll maybe farewell for
a day or even maybe one five minute
matches, something like that.
But man it doesn't, yeah,
Jujitsu is a self regulating.
See for the most part,
yes.
As self regulating seen very few people
can maintain and and most people with
bully bullying attitudes don't have the
humility to continue in Jujitsu for a
long time anyways. Yes, yes. So that's
another way that it's self polices.
So how do you find a good,
a Jujitsu Gym?
Obviously you start with Google,
you find out some locations.
To me proximity is very important.
So you want a place that's, you know,
on your way to work on your way
home from work close to your house.
So somewhere that you're going to get in
there and train because you don't want
to sign up for a gym and never go
because it's too far to out of the way.
So proximity is definitely a factor.
Then you got to ask yourself,
what are you looking for?
Because Jujitsu gyms very
tremendously in how they're set up,
how they're run and all those things.
I mean there's really super traditional
Brazilian Jujitsu gyms where they,
you bow before you get on the mat,
you bow after your,
you bow to the instructor when you're
going to talk to him. You are very,
they're very strict with uniforms.
So you know, only a white uniform,
you have to have this certain patch on
your uniform to represent the school.
That's,
that's one type of
atmosphere that you could have.
Then you could have a very loose
atmosphere where it's like, you know,
you're gonna come in, you're going
to train. There is no bowing.
There's handshakes and there's respect,
but it's not as overt and not as imposed
as it would be in a more traditional
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu school.
So what are you looking for?
You know, for me, I always,
you know, and, and if you
come to my gym, it's a very,
it's a very relaxed atmosphere in terms
of traditionally imposed discipline.
But when you roll there
will be disciplined in post.
But it's pretty dynamic though.
Like we have such a big group of people
that to go in there and in to get a non
competitive role is you can easily
do that. That's true. In fact, you,
it's easy to choose. It's
either easy to be like, okay,
I know Liz role with this group
and it's gonna. It's going be,
I'm going to go here with this crew
today and they're going to bring in,
or you know what?
I'm going to show what these guys over
here and we're going to work on some
technique and maybe I can ask this guy
about that. Yeah. So that's, that's good.
That is good. Um, you
know, there's also a,
are you going to go to a school that's
very focused on sport Jujitsu, which is,
hey,
we're going to compete,
we're going to learn the techniques that
are very applicable to two competing in
Jujitsu. Yeah. Um,
or am I going to do something that's
more towards self defense and or MMA.
And a classic example I think
of that is the, uh, is the 50,
50 guard where in this
position in Jujitsu,
if you don't know Jujitsu,
where if you're in a no rule situation,
you're very vulnerable to a devastating
submission called the heel hook.
And so it's,
but there's,
there's certain competition rules that
don't allow for heel hooks and that
position. So depending on
what kind of school you're at,
one of them you're going to get,
you're going to be in a,
in a different situation in that then
that one position. And, and you know,
actually at our school we do, we do
both. But do you want to do MMA focus?
Do you want to do GI or no GI?
And again,
there's benefits to both
those and they're both fun.
And I like training both. Um, so,
so you kind of kind of think about
what you're looking for and then,
and then bring that into the school and,
and then go try some classes,
take some classes at a school
and see what they're like.
What are the other students like,
you know,
what kind of atmosphere is it a,
do they have like the similar goals? If
you want to compete, if that's your goal,
then are the other people that
you talk to, are they like, yeah,
I compete all the time.
There's a tournament coming
up or are they like, yeah,
you know,
we can beat sometimes.
Or actually I don't care about competing
because there's plenty of people that
train Jiu Jitsu. They don't care
about competing. Is there, you know,
what's the attitude?
What's is their egos are people rolling?
If you try to kill you,
which,
which 99% of the time and a Jujitsu
school is not going to happen,
but it can happen, it can happen. So
what WWE and then, and then it's like,
what was the instructor like?
Is the instructor personal?
Is it is the instructor,
you know what we were
talking about earlier,
is he clearer as you concise as he
understand, can you understand him?
Can you understand the way he's
explaining moves now there's,
you got to give a little leeway there.
If you jump into a class
that's an advanced class,
you're not going to understand everything.
You know,
and people ask me on how to get
started on Jujitsu and I tell him to go
immersion training just like a language.
Just get in there and start training and
you're going to get destroyed at first
and then you're going to slowly learn and
the next thing you know that's fastest
way to learn languages to get an
immersed in it and do the same thing with
Jujitsu.
Is The instructor having fun?
Is the guy having fun or the girl?
Are they having fun teaching?
Is it a fun thing?
Because you want you Jitsu to be fun
and you want the instructor to be having
fun because there's instructors not
having fun. Well then what? You know,
what are they going to be like in six
months if they're not having fun today?
And then what, what are they going
to be like in six months? So that's,
that's another important piece
when you talk about what, um,
what you're looking for,
you know, in, in Jujitsu
and in my experience,
there's so many elements of
it to look for. Like if, you
know, when you, if you say,
okay, am I, do I want to learn
MMA learning MMA or fighting?
Is the sport of fighting compared
to like for example, the, the,
the Gracie Academy Torrance there.
Do you do to self defense in regards
to fighting getting into a fight or if
someone attacks you in a fight that's
way different than training in MMA
training. MMA is a sport of MMA. You're
going to learn a lot of moves. The,
you're not,
you're probably not going to learn
things that a quote unquote an attacker,
I mean you will,
but it's not focused on that.
You're not gonna learn stuff that
an attacker is going to do to you.
So in that differentiation is
just the fighting part alone.
It's not to mention the competition part,
the Biggie, the Nogi, the, you know,
all these dynamic moves.
Like,
if you go 10th planet and 10th Planet
compared to like Gracie Academy,
Torrance are almost like two different
sports almost yet. And they are,
but at the same time, you're going
to get, you're going to get Jujitsu,
that that's a, you're going to
get you to do for you and it,
and that's the important thing
is you can't judge it too.
And just like we talked about the
evolution of your principals, let your,
you know,
your game should evolve as well.
And almost everybody that's never done
Jujitsu before. If you said, well,
why do you want to take Jujitsu? 90% of
them are going to say, oh, self defense,
right? Because you know, people say,
I want to learn to defend myself.
There's not too many people that are
going to be saying, you know what,
I really have become interested in
this cerebral aspect of Jujitsu,
which maybe some people that listen to
us talk about it or listen to Joe Rogan
talk about it, you know, they'll say, oh,
that guy's talking about this thing
as if it's a very cerebral experience.
So maybe someone but,
but most people, yeah,
I want to learn how to defend
my cell phone and make sure so,
but you're going to evolve past that
because after six months of training,
you can handle yourself
on the street regardless.
If you went to 10th or you
went to the Gracie Academy,
you're going to be able to
handle yourself in the street.
And so then it becomes an obsession
of how did that move happen.
And so that's what you got to,
that's what you got to be ready to evolve.
And when you're at that point,
if you go to school a versus
if you went to school,
be your experience is going to be a lot
different and it's going to depend on
what you were looking
for in the beginning. But
nonetheless, yeah, if, if it is
obviously if it's a Jujitsu
school yeah. That, that,
that part's not really going to change.
Yeah.
You're going to learn Jujitsu,
which is a beautiful thing.
The other thing that I got
to say is you got it Jujitsu.
As much as I love it,
Jujitsu is not a religion.
And you know,
the,
the black belt instructor at the
school does not have contact or direct
communications with God.
Right?
So just I think,
keep that in mind.
It's a person that is trained in
a sport for longer than you. Okay?
So just keep that in mind.
It's not a cult there.
There should be an open atmosphere.
In my opinion.
You should be looking for a Jujitsu
school that has an open atmosphere,
not a cult controlling atmosphere.
Um,
you know, that being said, and,
and I said this already, respect.
Yes,
absolutely.
You should respect the people that are
there and respect your training partners
and respect your instructors for sure.
But you shouldn't be worshiping them
and they shouldn't be expecting you to
worship them. So just be
advised, because Jujitsu,
it should be fun. It should be
friendly, it should be engaging.
The atmosphere should be good and it
should be competitive without being
cutthroat. You know, you,
you should want to go without fear of
having a death match every single night,
unless that's what you're looking for.
And you just said that echo,
I mean like I go in every night
looking for a death match against Dean,
against you,
against Andy,
against Craig or Greg.
I mean our crew of murderers,
I'm, I'm going in for a
death match every night.
And even when I don't want to death match,
I give it to them because,
because that's how I'm getting better.
And that's part of my own personal
will to say, you know what? Regardless,
I'm in there to put it on the line and,
and throw it out there.
And if they get the best
of me, cool. So be it.
I learned I got better and I definitely
got better than I would if I was either
a sitting on the side of the mat,
be rolling with someone that's not
as good or see staying at home.
So yeah.
Yeah. That's so interesting how, how
it really does accommodate who you are.
Like you, when you, when you go in
looking for it, a death match every night,
that totally makes sense because of who
you are and who I understand you to be.
But at the same time, in the same gym?
On the same mat. Yeah. Yeah. He can have,
there's people chilling and in
who's, you know, he's, you know,
he ends up getting his black belt,
a bunch of knowledge,
but he's not going for any death
match, you know, older guy. Um,
that's what's so in my
opinion, good about it. Yeah.
So eight accommodates who
you are so much like me,
I do both like some days death match.
Sure. But most days, just like once every,
every
two weeks, once every two weeks we
get the death match. Rebecca? Uh,
so yeah, go out there, enjoy Jujitsu,
but we'll make sure you
don't fall into a cult.
Next, do you eat fruit? And if so,
how often? And if not, why not?
No. So, okay. Do I eat fruit?
Sometimes I eat fruit, but if you were
to ask me if you should eat fruit,
I would basically say no. I don't
recommend it. And again, this is just a,
if you talk to Dom D'agostino,
who's a doctor or Mister Paleo
himself, Robb Wolf, have you,
if you go and listen to his
podcast or doctor Peter Attia,
who I've talked about before,
these guys,
they know what they're talking about and
they will tell you what I'm telling you
and these guys will back it up with
science, upon science, upon science,
fruit, carbohydrates, Spike your
insulin level, just not good for you.
Um, again, am I an extremist?
No. Have some blueberries.
Get your blueberries on. Get your
blackberries on. That's awesome.
But take a bunch of fruit and put it
with some apple juice and mix it up in a
blender and eat,
you know,
400 grams of carbohydrate in
one shot. No, don't do that.
It's not good for you.
Have you ever eaten,
and I'm not saying when you're
on the program, so to speak,
have you ever eaten a whole box of donuts?
Negative?
Have you ever eaten,
ate a bag of Hershey's kisses
than it did not make, did not work out
good? When you say you don't eat fruit,
that's more of like when you're on the
program, right? Yeah. And did your,
you want to know when I'm on
the program? Yeah, but when,
when are you on the wall?
But yeah,
I when when you're,
when you're trying to eat clean,
which you should be trying to eat clean
80% of the time as anyone will tell you,
um, you know, keep it clean
and, and keep it to, you know,
fat and in protein.
If you can do it,
little bit of a subject change.
When,
if ever,
is it a good time to blow up at someone
to lose your temper will blow up at
someone and lose your temper? Two
different things, right? Does I think,
is it good? I think, I think most people
would think that they are the same thing.
Losing your temper and
blowing up at someone.
And I can tell you that is
almost never good to do that.
And when I say almost never,
I mean never with the tiniest caveat of
there is some possible scenarios where
it might need to happen. So if you lose
your temper and you blow up at somebody,
what do you,
what are you showing?
You're showing that you
can't control your temper.
And if you can't control your temper, then
what can you control? Right? That the,
and I'm not saying you should show no
emotions because if you show no emotions
in your robot and robots can't lead
people and people don't follow robots.
So there's some,
obviously some level of
showing emotions is needed.
But if you're losing your temper,
you're not thinking clearly.
And if you're not thinking clearly
because you've lost your temper,
you can't even read their reactions
to what you're saying and you're,
the fact that you're blowing up is,
is clouding your own vision.
The fact that you're losing your temper is
clouding your own vision.
And so you got to detach in order to be
observant in order to watch what your
actions are.
So if you do have to blow up and when,
okay,
so when, when is this almost
never happened? If you,
if you were working for me and you did
something wrong and I said echo and it
was grievous,
it was like pretty grievous.
Like it could've got someone
hurt and I said, echo, hey,
do this was bad.
This is what happened.
I don't know what I did wrong that
thought that made you think that would be
okay.
But whatever I image I gave you
that made you think this was okay,
I, this is the worst mistake I've ever
made. We can never let this happen again.
Okay. And you're like, yeah, okay. And
then four days later you do it again.
And I'd come at the same approach, maybe
a little bit different. Like, Hey, echo,
I don't know if there's anything I could
do to make this more clear than I did.
What can I do to make you understand?
So we might go three or four or five
iterations, maybe one more iteration,
I should say three iterations of you,
not you failing to do what you're supposed
to do and getting someone hurt her
almost getting someone
hurt. So now I go, okay,
he hasn't listened to
the indirect approach.
He hasn't listened to the direct approach.
He hasn't. I've taken ownership of it.
He hasn't taken any yet. I need to come
at them from different angles. Okay,
I need to lose my temper with them and
it's going to be a calculation and I
won't actually lose my temporary,
but I will raise my voice.
I will get loud.
I will point and I will make damn sure
that you understand that this infraction
that you have committed is severe and
grievous and can never happen again.
And that's the situation where I would
quote unquote blow up at somebody.
It is so rare that
it's so rare that in my military
career off the top of my head,
I can remember one and only one
incident of this where I actually said,
you know what? This,
this was a bad mistake.
I could see where these guys think they
might be able to get away with us again
in the future and I'm going to make sure
that they realize that was it the kind
where they,
it's not like they made the same mistake.
It was more like they
chose to do something,
they chose to do something a certain way.
And in my,
my assessment of it was that they
would do it again if I didn't make it
perfectly clear that this
could never happen again.
And so I raised my voice,
I pointed in the face and you know,
gave them 20 seconds of,
of intensity and the situation never
happened again and they apologized.
But overall not a good thing.
Don't lose your temper people don't do it.
Yeah.
I would say losing your temper,
not blowing up at someone,
losing your template for losing it.
You can be hard.
It's going to be hard to think of a
situation where that's cool. Yeah. Okay.
And I'll tell you, you want to know when
I lose my temper or cause I'll tell you,
I do lose my temper.
It happens once every six months and it
is almost always with inanimate objects,
namely objects that print or copy
or compute in some way.
You know, electronics,
sometimes I, I get, I get angry. Yeah,
you're going to probably want to
keep that in private areas, right.
You don't want people to see that.
Yeah.
Like my wife will hear me once
every six months, you know?
And she'll come in and she'll
be like a printer then. Oh yeah.
She says you're stupid. I go, I know. She
goes, it doesn't care if you yell at it.
I say, yeah, I know. I
might experience that.
I found the same thing looking. We're
looking. Okay, here's the next question.
Your specific lifting workout, your weekly
training schedule, including Jujitsu.
This is a big question.
And this,
for those of you that do
Jujitsu out there in the world,
this is like when someone says, Hey,
Hey Jocko, how do I pass your guard?
Cause I have a good guard. And so you
know someone that is a blue belch,
we'll say, you know, hey, how do I pass
your guard? You know, and they, and,
and literally I have guys at the gym
that are brown belts and black belts that
pass my guard once every six months,
you know,
so my guard is good and you know,
here's a blue belt. Like, hey,
how do I pass your guard?
So this,
this question kind of reminds
me of that a little bit. Um,
specific lifting workout
and weekly training schedule
on Jujitsu. So this is a,
this is a big ask. And here's
the problem that I have with us.
I'm an individual and I have
strengths and weaknesses.
I have whatever little injury thing
that I'm working through at a particular
time.
I have things that I liked to do and
I have things that I don't like to do.
I have,
um,
I'm an individual and my
workout is for me and,
and I've taken, and I've,
you know, sometimes people,
I'll go on a trip and there'll be a guy
that's an athlete and he'll say, oh, do I,
you know, I want to, I want to go through
one of your workouts with you. And I say,
okay. And I've done that.
And, and I've had guys,
okay,
like almost hospitalized from going
through one of my workouts and
that's not good.
And then I've had other guys,
like there's guys out there that will
just crush me in a workout, you know?
And especially,
you know,
there's workouts that I have that
I could beat most of the world in.
You know,
there's workouts that I have that
I could crush anybody in end.
Then there's workouts that some,
you know,
Yoga instructor could put me
through that would crush me. Right?
So my point is that you
get some people that I,
that would die due to one of my workouts
and you get some people that would it
be my one of my workouts is no impact
because they're an incredible athlete.
And so why would either one
of them want to do my workout?
It's doesn't make any sense
that they would want to do that.
So what I've been trying to think,
cause I get asked all the time, we are,
what's your workout? What's your
workout? What's your workout?
And it's what I've been trying to
figure out is how to do this. How do I,
how do I communicate what
I'm doing and what I've,
what I've been kind of
going through the idea in my
head is putting together a, uh,
like an ebook and I actually put this
out on Twitter. I was like, Oh yeah,
I'll do an ebook. And people like
Ebook, Ebook, yeah. Do it, do it.
So it's an idea that's already been
floated out there. Unfortunate,
there's not been a lot of
time to be writing ebooks,
but what the focus would be would be,
yeah,
like the types of exercise that
I do. Yes. But, and you know,
kind of the numbers of that I,
that I do have them,
but more importantly going to from a
leadership perspective is what is the
intent? What does the
commander's intent of my workout?
What am I trying to accomplish?
Because for you and me to accomplish
the same thing is going to be a dif,
very different workout.
Right. If, if I want to,
if I want to take myself to a,
to a,
to an anaerobic threshold
for a total of 15 minutes,
what I would do to get there is very
different from what you would do to get
there. It just, it just is,
if I wanted to destroy my
legs with heavy squats,
it would be very different between
what you would do and what I would do.
So what's important is,
is not the actual
exercises that I'm doing.
It's the intent and emi
achieving that a tent.
It am I achieving that intent.
Like I can do a decent amount of pullups.
Right.
And,
and in one of my pull up workouts,
I might do 500 pull ups or 300 pull ups.
There's a lot of people that can't do a
hundred pull ups. So just in the workout,
right? Not 300 bullets. Yeah, no, I
can't do 300 per pull ups in a row. No.
I wish I could, but, but my
intent is to, you know, Mack do,
do a number of maximum sets of pull
ups and then do a number of slow,
you know,
very good form maximum sets and,
and the intent is to get stronger
at pull ups by doing, you know,
have high number of maximum sets.
And I think that intent to
give to people would say, okay,
so that way if echo's not good
at Bob's and you go, okay,
well I'm going to go in and
I know what the intent is.
I'm trying to get to a point of
failure even on one single pull up.
And it might take you only 15 minutes
to do that and 30 pull ups, you know,
or whatever the case may
be. And for someone that's
really good, a rock climber,
it might take them,
you know,
45 minutes and they might be 600
pullups deep before they get there.
And so that's kind of the
idea I'm batting around.
I don't know if people have
that really interested in that.
I think a lot of times
people want a formula
and I don't think I'm going to give out
a formula because the formula is going
to be different for different people at
different times in their lives and ages
and body weights and you know,
male or female.
They're just all so many variables.
But I think if I can give out what
the intent of my workouts are,
then we're in the right place.
Yeah.
But those,
those different variables and stuff that
that could very well be the reason that
people want your workout.
Cause it's this two things,
this is probably more than two,
but two big things that kind of come
along with wanting your specific workout.
And one would be just to kind of immerse
myself into what you go through in a
workout and how does that feel
and how do I kind of measure up,
you know? Um, and then
so those two things,
like what does it feel like to do a Jocko
workout? Like how she, how hard is it,
you know, he's going to do, you
know, 600 pull ups in a workout,
limited lithy you know, like
how does that feel? You know,
is that the hardest thing I've ever
done or you know, is that just all this,
you know, these workouts are,
that heart just goes right.
That's the second part, does it, you know,
how do I measure up if he does,
you know,
20 sets of squats with whatever,
wait,
how do I measure up?
Can I get all those 20 sets or can I
get that weight for 20 cents? You know,
so those two, one, they just want
to immerse themselves in your world,
in your world as far as workouts go. And
the second one is, how do I measure up?
I know that's kind of what I think
when, when someone's like, Oh, here's,
here's our workout,
like those crossfit workouts,
like some of those just
mentally I do that like, okay,
this guy's doing 20 pull ups in a
row. Like how many can I do? You know,
I measurement. And then at the
same time, it's like, this is,
you get to understand
what these crossfitters do
can be, you know, and then like I
said, they go back and forth that,
those two things. And I think
that that, that is interesting.
Like if you were to tell me what
you did this morning for a workout,
like I'd be interested on
top of the fact that, oh,
maybe I want to do that workout for me
for results for myself and yet your item,
it may or may not, I'll probably have
different results even if I do that.
The same workout as you for,
you know,
six months old might
have different results.
But that part about measuring up and
just knowing who you are and kind of what
you stand for. And this is the workout
that you do. Just understanding that.
I think that's significant.
Yeah. I would love to tell you that
I'm some, you know, physical specimen,
but I'm not, I'm actually not the
strongest guy. I'm not the fastest guy.
I'm not the most flexible guy.
Um,
I try hard and I also am a result of my,
my physical aptitude is like a,
okay,
is like a, is like a brownish gray, um,
paint because I mix up so much stuff
in there that I'm the result of,
you know, I'm not bright red. Right.
I'm not bright blue because
those two things, you know, the,
the strength has been mixed
with endurance, has been
mixed with flexibility,
has been mixed with all these
things had been mixed together.
And I don't want to get too much of
any of them because then I'm losing
something else. And so the,
so I'm kind of this, this,
this kind of average
in many categories and,
and my numbers in very few of them,
motor impress anybody.
You're pretty strong now. Yeah.
And, and, and, and, you know, like,
but I'm not one of those people
that's on the mat that you go, man,
that guy is just freaking
strong. You know, we'll least, I,
it's hard for me to judge, but I know
that, uh, I guess people say, Oh,
you're strong. Yes. Yeah, I think that,
okay. You're like that guy on the,
you know, you ever play video games? No.
So let's say you play a, I dunno,
a football game, you play football,
so when you analyze your players,
it'll have all these attributes,
speed, hands, acceleration. Right. And
it's like, I don't know, zero to 10.
So you're the guy who has all like eight.
Yeah. Instead of the guy with
two tens and then a three.
But like anybody that's listening this
podcast beat me in a bunch of categories.
Yeah. You know, they got
tens and some stuff. Right,
right. Yeah. And, and I don't,
I don't have any tenants in
anything. That's okay. Not
everyone can have tenants.
Yeah.
Um,
next question. Question. Yeah. Um,
would you talk more about how you view
aggression positive than negative?
Well,
I like everything
in life and in leadership
and then your personality,
it has to be balanced. Aggression has to
be balanced. And you know, one of the,
one of the things from,
from the book is, you know,
you gotta be aggressive but
not overbearing. So yeah,
you gotta be aggressive.
To be a leader,
you've got to be there.
Because if you're going
to make things happen,
you've got to be aggressive to
make things happen that you,
you have to make things happen. You
know, I always say to people like, oh,
they want to make money. I'm like, well,
you use it. Make money. You have to take,
you have to take that money. It
doesn't get, I got a phone. Your House,
lean your lap. It's not going to
make itself. You have to take it.
If that's what your goal is in Jujitsu,
you're,
you're not going to get better just
by being, you have to take the,
the progression. You have to
take it and make it happen. And,
and that's the same thing
with anything in life. So,
so aggression definitely comes into play,
but for instance,
in a leadership position,
if you're completely
aggressive all the time,
your subordinates will not
want to communicate with you.
They won't want to debate with you.
They won't want to say, hey boss,
I don't agree with what you're saying
here because they're afraid you're gonna
go, hey, you don't know
what you're talking about.
We're going to go my way or the highway.
That's what they're going to expect.
So you can't be overbearing,
you know, on the Mat,
you can't exhaust yourself with
aggression. And that's one of the things,
you know that I think from purple
to Brown belt, which is, you know,
you're,
you're six to eight years in the game
is where people start to calm down and
realize that that aggression needs to be
tampered and control and people have to
relax. Um, adding combat,
obviously being aggressive and being
dis aggressively decisive is important.
But if you go too far with that,
you're running to your death.
So you have to modulate your aggression.
You have to modulate your aggression.
You can't abuse it. You got to
use it, but you can't abuse it.
And I don't want to discount
aggression in any way because you know,
I always say that your default mode
should be aggression.
Like when you,
when you hit the reset
button on your brain,
you should come out of that reset being
aggressive because that, that beat,
be aggressive, be proactive,
make things happen.
Okay.
Be on offense,
you know,
not sitting back and waiting
to be attacked or waiting
for a situation to occur.
No. Make that situation occur. Go.
So that's my view of aggression and,
and it just has to be balanced.
And there's other,
or some times where,
you know,
if you meet aggression with aggression,
it's actually not good. You know,
you,
you see this in Jujitsu,
you see this in escalating in when you're
either in a confrontation of some kind
to somebody aggressively escalating,
something might be a good choice.
It might be a bad choice.
You know, there's always the
bully that as soon as you,
you say, hey, you know what,
I'd love to fight. In fact,
fighting is my favorite thing to do. Let's
go. I've got it. It's like, no man. Oh,
was it? I was just kidding.
So aggression will when there,
um, or you know, if someone's really being
aggressive and you just knock them out,
well then that's,
that's a better handling of the situation.
But there's also times where there's,
you know,
maybe there's multiple attackers or
there's someone that's, you know,
you're in the street.
It's,
it's always better in the street to
avoid the confrontation. You know,
what does that person have a knife?
Does that person have a gay gun?
Is does that person have
a communicable disease?
Does that person have
friends around the corner?
Is that personal lawyer
who's going to sue you?
I mean there's all these reasons to get
into to to not get into a fight in the
street.
So,
so aggressively meeting aggression with
aggression is probably not that smart.
It's probably better to
avoid the scenario. And,
and the more time you spend in,
you know,
in combat sports boxing
and doing Jujitsu them,
the more likely you are to be
able to be like, you know what,
I don't need to prove anything in this
guy. I'm, it's, it means nothing to me.
I proved myself on the mat every
single day. I got nothing to prove to,
to Joe drunk idiot over here.
So I think that a Gra,
again,
I think your default mode
should be aggressive,
but make sure that you maintain enough
detachment of the situation that you can
see if you're being overly aggressive
and it's leading you to a bad scenario.
Okay, last question. You talk
about mind control. Okay.
Can you expand your
thoughts on that subject?
Mind control.
You know,
when people think of
the word mind control,
they think of controlling
other people's minds.
And when I think about mind control,
I think about controlling your own mind.
Because you know,
while I am obviously a physical person
and we'd spend a lot of this podcast
tonight talking about physical
culture and I embrace physicality,
but we are our minds and I'm not going to,
you know, going, uh,
into a Sam Harris Philosophical rant on
what it means and where the you actually
is and whether there's a soul or a brain
or whatever your heart or some other
conjured up place.
This is what I know is that you,
your mind,
the thing that is listening and
comprehending these words right now,
that is you and that thing,
that mind you can control
you.
You are the machine and you can
control the machine and people ask me,
how do I get tougher? Be Tougher. They,
they asked me,
how can I wake up earlier in the morning?
The answer is wake up
earlier in the morning.
How can I work out
consistently every single day
workout consistently every single day?
How can I stop from eating sugar?
Stop eating sugar.
What about the emotions?
How can I stop missing that
girl or that guy, whoever,
whoever broke up with me,
how can I stop missing them?
Stop missing them.
Okay.
That is mind control.
You have that ability.
You just have to assert it.
You have to decide that you're going to
be in control and that you are going to
do what you want to do.
Weakness doesn't get a vote.
Laziness.
They don't get a vote. Sadness, no,
no vote. Frustration, no vote. Negativity.
You don't get a vote.
I don't even give my temper a vote.
So the next time that you're feeling
weak or you're feeling lazy or you're
feeling soft or you're feeling emotional,
tell them that they don't get a vote.
Tell them you are declaring
martial law on your mind.
You're declaring mind control
and impose what you want on your brain.
Impose the discipline and the power
and the positivity and the will
and use that mind control to move your
life where you want it to be is the,
I always say get stronger,
faster, smarter, quicker,
friendlier, more helpful, more driven.
Okay.
Don't let your mind control you.
Control your mind
and once you control your mind,
then
you can set it free.
And I think we'll close with that for
the day. Yeah, that's about all I've got.
I right there.
And you know if you're out there
and you want to communicate with us,
you want to carry on this conversation,
you want to continue down this path.
You can do so on Twitter.
I'm at Jocko Willink and
echo is at Echo Charles.
Hmm.
I want to thank everyone for listening.
I want to thank you for subscribing to
this podcast for placing reviews on this
podcast for spreading the
word about this podcast.
And most of all,
I want to thank you
for getting after it.
This is Jocko and Deco,
and until next time out.